oh hello everyone
welcome to real time revolution uh this
is signalr in action um
before we get started i always like to
tell a little bit of a story i'm an
independent consultant
in the united states i work with a
variety of
companies
all around the world um various
countries and i get the most
like basic questions that come across my
email i always try to do like a
15-minute call just get an idea where
people are and i had a client's come
last year give or take
and they said kevin we have an
application
not an actual screenshot i swear
i
i'm not very good with css i could
probably create something a little bit
prettier in css if i tried but their app
looked like this and you probably have
an app as well they look similar to this
it's
some icons up in the top right corner
there's a menu or toolbar and it does
some stuff
and they say kevin we have this
application and we have two very
important icons
on this page we have a
little envelope that tells people when
they're getting new messages that come
into the system and then we also have
this global alerts notifier
well what happens is when stuff happens
in the app these little icons pop up and
say you have two alerts that you need to
know about or you have five new messages
that you need to be aware of
and this is different for every user
and is up to date no matter how many
tabs i have open at any one time
and you probably have seen this dynamic
before if you've used facebook or any
similar applications you understand what
the badges do
if you don't open them they go away
stuff gets synced back to the server
the the way they accomplished this was
they had their app
so we talked to their web server and
every now and then it would go and say i
need to know the number of unread
messages that i currently have or
it would go say well what are the number
of alert notifications that i need to be
aware of
it's the client specifically going to
the server asking it for information
it's doing a pull request technically
and would do this
both calls
every five seconds
every five seconds okay not a big deal
except
you make this assumption as just one
person using your app
it's not really one person using your
app it's
multiple people using your apps and if
your users are anything like mine they
have multiple tabs open multiple windows
maybe on multiple devices
they're all hitting the same server
and they're all
getting the same information over and
over again and they took the process of
trying to optimize in different ways
they couldn't necessarily cache that
information long term because it's
always changing stuff is always
happening on the server those statistics
are always changing so they try to do
funny things with like tab caching so
one tab might go
grab the information and share it with
their other tabs and they try to over
architect what could be a simpler
solution
and they went to their telemetry and
their telemetry said that 90 of their
calls were those two specific endpoints
because every client every five seconds
was hitting them trying to get new
information that wasn't necessarily
changing all the time
so we asked ourselves and they asked me
and they paid me kevin is there a better
way that we can accomplish this
well you already know there is because
you wouldn't be here if there wasn't a
bear way
hi everyone i'm kevin griffin from the
united states uh microsoft mvp
independent consultant my primary focus
in life and career is building web
applications on asp.net core
and deploying solution to microsoft
azure so i'm happy to be here with you
all today if you ever like to reach out
to me afterwards you can go to my
website consultwithgriff.com
or hit me up on twitter at one kev griff
i would love to chat with you
i also have a best-selling course on
udemy uh on signalr which
i went and grabbed the screenshot in
pounds today because dollars wouldn't
have made any sense to anyone uh so it's
really cheap at the moment you should go
grab it but i'm not going to push my
course anymore than this
let's talk about a better way to solve
that problem
i have my app i have my server and the
ideal solution you probably already know
the ideal solution is just set up a
websocket between the clients
and the server
because there's this great thing that
happens when the server gets a message
it knows
everything that's happening it is the
ultimate state of truth
for our entire ecosystem if an email
comes in the server knows about it if a
direct message comes from another client
it knows about it if the databases needs
to be updated the server knows about it
because the server is the one doing the
work
so the server is aware of everything
that's happening in our app so why
couldn't the server just send that
message down to the client to tell it
that something occurred
email comes in the server sends the
message down to the client the client
increments decrements
changes
its notification to reflect what the
current state of the server is
and this works really well at scale
so instead of all these various clients
making calls multiple calls every five
seconds to get
various pieces of information
they just establish a single connection
a websocket and when something happens
the server will notify
whomever needs to know about it
now it might not be every client that
needs to get a message it might be
uh specific clients
it might just be your one tab or your
one tab or your one tab
everyone gets the message that they need
at the time that they need it
even better what if we could have
a system where i write code one way
but that code supports not just
web pages
it could also support multiple devices
windows apps
windows services
mobile apps
you name it
what if i could write one server
implementation that could feed all these
different types of applications that i'm
building
so you probably already guessed it that
solution is signalr which has been in
the asp.net
framework since
2013. i believe that was the first
course i created on signalr
it was added as this way to really make
websockets more approachable to net
developers because if you ever had a
program a raw websocket
it's easier now than it was 10 years ago
but it's still kind of a pain in the
butt it's a lot to manage
especially across numerous users
and signalr just abstracts all that away
from you
even better
if you have a case where websockets
isn't supported you don't have to change
your code in any way signalr is
automatically going to find the best way
for your clients and your server to
communicate with each other
so okay i want to jump out of slides for
a minute i want to start just running
through some basic
demos
and when i say basic
i mean basic i have this philosophy
when it comes to signal r
that the simpler the demo the better
there's so many folks that want to show
you a chat demo
there's an unwritten rule in the signalr
community you do not write chat demos if
someone
writes a chat demo in single r
there's any microsoft folks in here
good microsoft vote yes all right don't
tell anyone i said this microsoft folks
break this all the time like chat chat
chat chat chat don't write chat demos
uh instead i'm just gonna show you the
world's ugliest demo
uh let's set it up real fast
i have this starter this is all on
github so you can see it after the fact
if you want
nope that's not it
i want to set up what our intention is
with this demo you see this is the
world's ugliest demo it just says hi
uh i have a text box i have a check box
i also have a couple buttons and there's
a couple phases to this demo our
ultimate goal
and this is 90 of what i do in signalr
is when i type something into that first
text box
i want it to also display on that second
text box signal r the majority of the
work you're going to do in cinema is
state transfer something happens in the
system and i need to notify the clients
about it i need the transfer state when
state changes
now it doesn't do anything at the moment
because we haven't wired up any signal r
so if i just type kevin
nothing happens
so let's start fixing that
bits by bit by bit
i'm going to shut down my
application let's walk through the code
just a little bit so you see where we're
starting with
i try to keep everything simple again
our html input box
check box a couple buttons that we'll
get to later
i have my scripts at the very end
for including signalr plus some
other
fancy tools
when you primarily use signalr in a real
application you're probably using
something like webpack or some sort of
build system
so you're going to npm install your
signalr dependency and you'll just
include it wherever necessary
for this demo i'm just using signalr
kind of raw raw javascript but the
syntax that i'm using is fairly similar
to what you would write in typescript or
just raw javascript
the
javascript itself
nothing up my sleeve i have a couple
placeholders just for event handlers
but there's no signalr in this
application yet
well let's start at the very beginning
in our startup cs
if you're working with new minimal apis
it's just program cs
but we have two things that we need to
do here
the first is we need to configure
services for signalr
and that's
fairly straightforward
say services.add cigar
sigma r is already a part of the box
when you create a new asp.net core
application
no special nuget packages that you need
to install
the second thing we have to do is create
a place
for our clients to connect
and traditionally in signalr this is
called a hub
if you're familiar with
mvc model view controller you understand
the concept of controllers and
controller is a place that connections
go to perform work
in signalr a hub
is a place that web sockets go signal
our connections go to
basically be managed by signalr
so all of our connections will go
through
what we call the hub
i'm going to create one called a sync up
i'm doing a lot of this by hand
and it implements the class or the type
hub
which is part of signalr
now this is
all i really need to do for now
my hubs don't have to have any methods
in them they can just simply exist
for
managing connections
if i go to
my startup i have to register that hub
with asp.net core
and that's done through the use
endpoints
middleware
we'll say configure
map hub
i need to tell asp.net core what type of
hub i want to
implement so i'm going to say sync hub
and i have to give it a path and that
path is going to be hubs
slash sync
of course there's no formatted for c
sharp
all right
so we're going to save that we're going
to go back to our app and make sure this
compiles
nope because
i don't have the namespace
so this is using
microsoft's asp.net core signal r
there we go all right
that's step one step two let's go back
to our javascript file
we have a hub on our asp.net core app
it's exposed an endpoint we need to set
up a connection between our clients and
our server
so that's
done with what's called the connection
hub builder so we'll
create a new connection
which will create a new
signalr
hub
connection builder
and i have to tell this
hub connection builder
where to go to connect
uh so there's a couple options on here
we'll say with url we'll tell it hubs
just sync
and then i'm going to tell it to build
itself
so our creates the connection but it
hasn't really done anything yet the
connection is created but we have to go
tell it to start the connection
which is done down here at the bottom
and in your application the connection
can start whenever you want to
typically i try to start the connection
as soon as possible when a page renders
just because it's nicer to have that
socket open and ready to go for when you
need it then wait until a later time
we're going to say net
run
we'll open this in a browser again i'm
going to bring up the dev tools this
time
let's do a refresh
come on
signalr is not defined yes it is
signal r capital r
there we go so a couple things happens
here our page renders
you see the first line we're normalizing
our url so it's fully qualified uh you
can also use signalr across domains uh
there's core support uh we don't need
that in the moment
but then my second line which was this
dot start
signalr does a couple things you can see
we have websocket connected at our
endpoint
but the process to get there
let's find our network tab
let's go back to all
let's bring this up a little bit more a
couple things happened
uh first was this negotiation call
uh the clients and the server have a
little chat
and they ask what's the best way for us
to talk to each other because they
really want to be on the same page
ideally they want to use web sockets but
sometimes there are cases where
websockets can't apply we'll talk about
that in a moment
if websockets works they say websocket
is the way we're going to go the server
assigns a connection id which is unique
to this tab this instance
and then the next call to sync
is an actual websocket that gets opened
back to the server with the
with the connection token and such
so now the
client and the server can talk over this
websocket as much as they want to we can
watch the messages here as they come
these are just uh
heartbeats coming in every couple
seconds so we've set up the scaffold for
now actually being able to send
information up and down the pipe
let's talk about protocols for a moment
so ideally you would use a websocket
which simply is an end-to-end connection
between all your clients and your server
so the server can send information up to
the clients the clients can send
information down to the server
but there are cases where websockets
cannot be used
not so much today but
maybe five six years ago this was the
case
every now and then you get a proxy or
some sort of vpn it doesn't allow
certain websocket connections sometimes
the server won't allow it or it's
disabled
if there's a case where a websocket
isn't supported there are a couple
fallbacks
there's one called server sentiments
which has been around since the netscape
days
and the way this works is that the
client makes an initial request to the
server saying i would like to
start
service and
events connection with you the server
returns what's called an event source
back to the client and this is a pipe
for the server
to send messages down to the client
whenever it wants to
and this is fantastic
however it doesn't work as well when the
client wants to send messages to the
server
the fallback is that the server just
makes traditional ajax requests or post
requests to the server whenever there's
a message that needs to get made
so this pipe is dedicated just for the
server
to go to the client and it will work in
95 of cases where websockets isn't
supported
for all the other cases
there's the final final fallback which
is long polling
uh long polling is just simply opening
the request to a server
the server maintains that connection
until it has something to say
so if there's no messages that need to
come down to the client immediately that
request is just going to stay open
as soon as the server has a message to
send
sends back the response the connection
closes we repeat the pattern
the only time
that the request would get terminated
prematurely is if the timeout expires on
the client side this could typically be
about two minutes but it's customizable
based off the browser
this is the final final fallback
just because this will work all the way
back to ie6
hopefully no one's supporting ie6
if you are raise your hands or we can
laugh at you
excellent uh so just quick
comparison normally you're going to use
websockets it's the de facto standard
nowadays it's always available
connection between a client and a server
uh there is a con because it's always
open connection
that's you could potentially exhaust
your socket pool
in your application
don't ask me how i found this out the
hard way
if we have time i will tell that story i
have learned that you can ddos yourself
accidentally with websockets
it's a good story
if websockets aren't available for any
reason proxies vpns say not
we fall back to server sent events which
are great but the only issue is that the
client can't use the server the event
source to send messages to the server
so it has to fall back
and then finally long polling which
works across all browsers it's just
horrible it's actually the problem that
we had at the very beginning of the talk
where we're constantly making requests
to the server over and over and over
again
uh so that's the worst case scenario
now you might be thinking kevin do i
have to write the code to handle all
these different cases well this demo
right here will handle all three of
these without any code changes on your
side
the only thing you could do or might
want to do is you might want to tell
your app don't use long polling or don't
use server sent events only use web
sockets that's just a quick
configuration
option
and you can do that i don't recommend it
unless you have a particular use case
but
that's all you need to know about the
transport protocols
so let's get into some meat let's send
some messages let's make this
boring demo actually do something
i'm going to close all this stuff shut
down my server
let's go back into our app
all right come on vs good there you go
all right uh no real good place to start
we're going to start in the hub
and we're going to worry about that
text box because that's
what we want to do first uh we have to
create a method on the server
that the clients can call
when it wants to update the state on
everyone's text box
so we'll create a new public async
method because
the any
signalr method inside of a hub will
return a task it's all asynchronous my
number one consulting gig
is awaiting people's signalr calls
because they don't realize that every
single hour method that you create is
asynchronous
it's literally the easiest money i've
ever made hey oh wait oh wait oh wait oh
wait wait
pay me please
uh so
just call this sync text box
and sync text box is going to take a
string
and we'll just say text box
and
when
this method gets called which it will be
called by a client we want to turn
around take the contents of text box
and send it to
all our connected clients
that aren't
the person making the call
so how do we get that connection list
well because we're implementing hub
we have this collection called clients
and this is a data structure that
knows about every single connection to
our server
at this time
i can say clients not all
and it will send a message to all the
connected clients including myself so
myself being if i'm the tab that's
making the request
but that's not not necessarily what i
want i want to send this to all the
others
that are connected to
this server
we'll say send async
and
i'm going to pass in a magic string
there's other ways to do this i'm just
using
magic strings for demo purposes
i need to tell
my clients
what method they need to execute on
their side
and again we're going to call this sync
text box just
to keep everything the same and we're
going to pass in
our string
and we're going to oh wait on this call
now kevin what happens if i don't wait
on this call
the message may or may not go through
it all depends on how your server is
feeling at that time
uh because what happens is if you don't
await threads might terminate
prematurely
it's a whole mess and then you call me
and i charge you a lot of money to fix
it
uh so we'll wait on our call seeing text
box
go over to the client
so let's go ahead and
set up
the first event so on our connection
we can say on
sync text box
let me pass in a function
so this is the local event sync text box
which correlates to
the call that we're making on the server
so technically when the server calls
the the clients to say hey sync text box
here's the text
this is the method that gets
called we are going to
take our text box
and set the value on it to text
yay
now what if
i'm the one changing the text box
all right i have the event handler set
up for the text box all the
fancy html stuff
we are going to go to our connection
and we are going to ask it to invoke a
method
on the server
called sync text box uh casing doesn't
technically matter here
and i'm going to pass in the value of
target
the value
type something in text box hit tab enter
whatever calls a change event
assuming we have an existing connection
we're going to send a message to the
server telling the server invoke
sync text box
with a given value
it's going to execute that method sync
text box
passing in the parameter which will turn
around and send the message to everyone
else
now that all sounds good let's make sure
i actually coded this correctly
nope
oh oh hey
uh remind me what namespace task is in
hey who said that
there you go
it's a task or tap
just system that's ready
here i'm going to owe you a cookie
nope never i don't owe you a cookie
hey there you go all right
thank you sir
all right let's assume everything
connected there's no
console errors oops
all right everything's good in the
console now
i'm going to create two instances of
this app
from side by side
and i want to type kevin and hit enter
when i hit enter we got our local event
handler it took this stuff out of the
text box send it to the server saying i
want to call the sync text box method
with the term kevin
turns around sends that to all the other
connected clients one
and it gets the value kevin drops it
into text box and we're all good
we put these side by side
we can show you it goes either way
yay
now i know that is not the most
impressive demo but that is 90 of signal
artwork is just handling messages uh
between the clients and the server in
this form
now those who don't like magic strings
there's a way to create what i i call
them strongly typed hubs
where you can create an interface
and everything can be strongly typed so
you don't have to say send async sync
text box um
that takes about 15 minutes to get into
so i'm not doing it in this talk but i
happen to have a course that talks about
all that stuff you can get it for 13
pounds
all right so for the sake of time i'm
not going to wire up the checkbox the
checkbox is basically the same thing
with a different data type so you notice
i'm passing it a string but i could very
well pass in a boolean i could pass in a
full object
what i want to get into now is actually
sending more complex objects but
selectively sending messages to only
people that want to get them
that's where these buttons come into
play start notifications
and end notifications
so one of the things that are that's
been happening in the background
is i've been running this
user generator
every 10 minutes
we go and generate a new user
and we don't do anything with it
what would be nice is
selectively sending that
message to
uh to our page only for the people that
want to receive those messages
so let's go into our code let's shut
this down real fast
and i'm going to add two more methods
start notify
and then end notify
so start notify is going to get called
whenever i press the start notifications
button and notify when i press end
notification you all can figure that out
when i press start notify i want to add
myself my connection
to what we call a group and a group is a
logical way to organize
connections in your applications
so maybe
uh when i log in
uh i'm an administrator so we might have
a special group for just administrators
or administrative connections
um i might
i might be looking at a widget
if i have a widget page well a specific
widget i might have a group for just
updates to a specific widget
when we're done i'm going to show you an
actual clients
application i wrote where we use groups
uh religiously
but just think of the idea of a group as
a logical grouping of of connections
so we're going to say groups
oh i don't have my intellisense
that's all right that's why i have notes
i'm going to add to group async
and this takes two parameters the first
is my connection id
now because i'm
implementing hub
i get clients i get groups i also get
this context
context represents the current
connection
for the current tab the current window
that's looking at this app
and it has a connection id
then i need to tell it which group i
want to
uh add this connection to
and we'll just call it notify me
all right
if i don't want to be in the group
anymore
or programmatically something happens
and i want to be removed from the group
i can say remove from group
and same thing context connection id
and i'll remove myself from notify me
excellent
let's go back to the javascript
all right i have my two buttons
now you might already be able to figure
out how we call these i can say invoke
start notify
and then
invoke
and notify this adds me to the group or
it takes me out of the group
let's wire up
a case where we actually want to do the
notification and for this
i'm going to bring up my sample code
just to copy and paste
here we go
so on the connection event
it will eventually get called new user
i'm going to get a user object from the
server and all i'm going to do with that
user object is display some toast
with the person's name and picture and
all that good stuff
over on the server
where am i going to get the notification
from
i'm taking advantage of asp.net core
background services
runs automatically runs forever until
you
shut it down
well i have a case here where i go to
the server go to a server get a user and
i have a to-do and to-do's are fun
aren't they
i mean it's work you have to do in the
future
let's go ahead and
all right i'll do this part by hand
i need to get a reference to all my
clients that are currently connected
well i can't do that easily because i'm
not in the hub i'm outside of the hub
and this is another common question how
do i send messages to users when i'm not
inside of a hub i might be in a
controller i might be in another service
or somewhere else in the app
well everything in signalr depends on
asp.net dependency injection so i can
inject
an ihub context
of sync hub
and this gives me
basically a reference to all my
connected clients on this server
so now i can come down where i say to do
signal r
i can send
i can say hubcontextclients.all
nope
group
i can pass in the name of the group
notify me
and tell them to send async
nope yep no then i'm right sorry
and what's the name of the method i
chose new user
so on the
message new user i'm going to pass in
uh was it r dot first dots
results dot first
all right let's assume again that i did
everything correctly this is build
the only unit test that matters
i failed oh because i was dominant
make it private
and then down here we'll say
oops
and that's not right
okay
let's try it again
oh i have a call that's not a way did i
bring my own rule
yes i did where were you all folks i
could have given you money for that but
oh well
yep
let's restart the app because we
definitely don't want to test that
theory right now
we'll restart
again
let's go ahead and open up a new
tab
make sure everything connects correctly
all right i'm going to say start
notifications
so what happened underneath the scene oh
there it comes right away all right so
welcome grayson
and we stay here and let it run for a
moment
every 10 seconds
every day hey we have no new person that
pops up
that's because i subscribe to the
notifications for
this particular
app
if i open up another tab
and they're both connected
all right we get the notification on one
side so i'll start notifications on the
right side oh wait a moment they should
both get the same notification
levi cool so
we're selectively sending messages only
to clients that want to receive them
if i hit endnotify on the right side it
should not get the next notification
because i've removed myself from that
group
there we go
let's talk a little bit deeper about
connections and groups
now i want to show you more fancy demo
stuff
all right so there's a
variety of ways to filter clients
uh the one that we
saw earlier so think about our
infrastructure like this we have our
server we could technically have two or
three or 15 or 50 000 servers
and
all of our connections are connecting to
this server
if i want to send a message to
all my clients
no matter what
i can filter my clients with the uh
the all collection so clients.all will
send a message to all
the connected clients that want to
receive it
sometimes i only want to send a message
back to the person that made the
original call so here when i press send
or start notifications
i am technically the caller the person
making the call to the server
now that was client a
the server might say well let's send a
message back to only the person that
made the original call
so only i gets that message
we saw earlier if i want to send the
message to everyone other than the
caller
i can say clients.others
a sends a message in everyone else gets
a response
this is really useful when you know a
already knows the new state so something
changed you don't need to
confuse
client a by sending the information back
to it
it really depends on the setup of your
app now this is where it starts to get
really weird you can filter connections
uh by connection id
so i could say send to all clients
except
connections c and e
so everyone else gets it uh these are
filters i've never used in a production
application i think they exist because
somewhere there was a design
meeting where they said oh this would be
a good idea to have i've never seen it
used
clients.client you can send to a
specific client so if you know the
connection id
of a specific client you can send a
message directly to them i don't
recommend this uh
there's a i have a
very long article on why you shouldn't
do this has to do with scaling and stuff
like that but i don't use this method
but you could if you wanted to
you can specify multiple clients
d and f if you and this is uh just a
list of parameters so you could stack as
many as you wanted to into that list
uh if you're using identity asp.net core
identity and you have an eye user
principle
you can use that user principle to
identify specific connections
if i told signalr to send a message to
kevin
signalr is going to know based off user
principle which connections are kevin
and it will send messages directly to
those
this is hit or miss
in my experience on in scaled
environments
locally it works great all the time
scaled environments it can be hit or
miss
you can specify multiple users so if you
know a variety of user principal names
you can send to everyone that you want
to
kevin and sally
then we can get into groups this is
where i i think the real power single r
is i use groups all the time
specifically as a solution to
managing connection ids
because it's so much easier to put
connections into a group and send to a
group instead of trying to manage
connection ids directly or even trying
to manage things like user principle
i will
in every application automatically put
an authenticated user into their own
group like user kevin
that way
anywhere in the application if i know
i need to send a message to kevin
i can send say group dot
user kevin
i don't care how many connections kevin
has kevin will get
the message on all
his connections
and this syntax is the same way
clients.group
send async
call a particular method on the client
uh oh so here i have the server and then
i have the connections broken up into
well it's supposed to be orange
orange and yellow
so only the orange group gets gets a
message you can filter this a little bit
more i don't do this either
everyone in the group accept a
particular connection or particular
connections
you could do this again i don't think
it's worth your time
you can send them multiple groups i've
done this a handful of times as well
so everyone in yellow everyone in orange
they all get the message
and if you're a caller in a group you
could say others in the group with me so
i'm connection a
i say send to all the others in the
group yellow
only b and c will receive the message
all right now i've talked a lot about
groups and all this stuff i've shown you
probably the worst demo ever
um
don't give me yellow on that please
or red
just give me green
i'm going to show you an application i
worked with this is a non-profit
based in the united states
called the national institute of public
safety technology
and
i'm going to bump this font up a little
bit for y'all
let me explain a little bit how it works
in the united states because so over
here was in 999 emergency services
in the united states we have 9-1-1
and
when you live in a populated city like
like a new york city or i'm from a place
called norfolk virginia
we have dedicated emergency services all
over the place
in some rural parts of the united states
you
you don't have emergency services right
down the street from you uh you might
have emergency services in a county over
or if they're in your county they're
they're miles and miles away
uh so the solution to the problem of how
do we get emergency services to people
as quickly as possible
we
i worked with this team to work on this
system called livecat that aggregates
emergency service data
from a variety of
uh call centers so if you call into
our 9-1-1 emergency services and say uh
i'm sick or
elevator emergency that sounds horrible
right now because
it is
seven in the morning on the west coast
on
midwest i'm trying to think of the time
there
yeah it's early and they're stuck in an
elevator that sounds bad
uh
so we're getting information from all
these emergency services you can
actually tell we have uh different
colors for the emergencies uh the
services so there's west
lc rcc and fair
uh
they're sending information in our
system we're quickly aggregating it
and we build these dashboards
for different
firehouses emergency services and
whatnot
so the way this works
in
in the firehouses
is someone might be
in the firehouse
looking at the the screen it's up on a
big tv and if something really bad
happens that i need to be aware of this
screen flashes bright red just over and
over again so thankfully that's not
happening right now
but when that happens it's our cue that
we need to suit up get into the truck
and head out to to a service call
when i first came on to this project
if the
the request wasn't like the the
beginning of the talk hey we're hitting
this end point too many times it was
worse like way worse uh they had a
dashboard it looked very similar to this
we didn't change the look too much
but it was uh asp.net
web forms who's done that
all right who remembers update panel
all right
this was in an update panel the whole
thing was an update panel not like
little update panels here there the
whole thing was an update panel
when that update panel rendered
it would go to the database the sql
server database on the same box as the
iis server
and it would ask the database all right
give me the the trucks the resources we
call them give me the list of incidents
that i need to know about for a
configuration
and
uh hey by the way also tell me what
color everything should be why are you
asking the database what color stuff
should be
so it's doing all this work on the
database it comes back builds the html
delivers the update panel re-renders the
screen and it does that every one second
across thousands of clients
and they said kevin
our cpu is like at 99 all the time and
we're maxing out all the memory and i
went
yeah
i can see what we can fix that
so we refactored we actually rewrote the
entire back end in
that
it's like dot-net 4.7 it was a newer.net
framework it was before core uh and we
had used signal r for net framework
and it has since been
uh refactored again it's now currently
running.net 6 it's all up to speed
so we
went through and we built it with this
concept of
we're sending data into the server
the server is going to aggregate it and
it's going to selectively send updates
to
clients
based off of
their configuration information so
if i look at this list
we have all these different
configurations of how data can be viewed
and they all have their own unique id
now i have a signalr group for all these
different ids
when i go to
let me just pick something
uh no active incidents
let's go back to mecklenburg that's a
is it better
because there's actually data in here
when i load this view
behind the scenes we make a call hey add
me to the group
oh 25 mech 3.
so now when the server gets data that
comes in and realizes hey
oh 25 meg 3 needs to know about this i
get a message telling me that something
has changed whether it's a resource or
an incident
but a lot of time like right now it's
just sitting here not doing anything
because there's nothing to be done
we deployed this
now we deployed it to an azure app
service so we made a change we took them
off the box under the table
and
uh we loaded up and i'm watching things
like cpu and memory utilization it was
like one percent
and people were hitting the server i'm
like oh crap i broke it i broke
something i i whatever i pushed in
production is not working um i'm like oh
crap they're gonna sue me this is gonna
be horrible
and turns out it's working just fine it
was just we had taken all the load off
the server all the load off the database
and we were using a more intelligent way
to send data down to different clients
so everything was push notifications
instead of pull notifications
and this has been running in production
for years
and we've just made updates to things
like the.net framework and to.net core
and keeping the libraries up to date
so the story that happened
after we pushed this out they got a
write-up in the industry magazine
that's uh uh there was
some folks in a firehouse
they were doing their normal
night shift stuff the screen started
flashing red
and
yep that's something we got to do
they get suited up they get in the truck
doors open truck is out the door
the moment the truck is out the door
a dispatcher comes over the intercom
says there's
medical emergency here's the address
whatever
folks are already out the door they're
heading towards the emergency
we have designed a system
that is faster than a person coming over
a
an intercom
and what's important about that
is maybe someone in here you have a
loved one
or even a person you don't like has had
a medical emergency like a stroke heart
attack
something that requires life-saving
attention as soon as possible you know
that every second counts
and we used
a silly thing like signalr
to build a system that gets emergency
personnel to
life-saving resources faster than a
human can get life-saving resources to
um to a person so that's why i tell
everyone i save lives
with websockets uh i actually have an
entire talk just on that on this app
um
that i i'm not doing here
but
this is kind of the culmination of all
the ideas and putting into real practice
not just theoretical like
dumb
dumb demo that i had before
but i have about nine minutes left
i am happy to answer any or all
questions that you have
thank you all so much for hanging out
with me here at ndc i hope you've
enjoyed yourself maybe learned something
yes sir
what point does signal our service come
into play without it
i've struggled i've got similar work on
my app yep
functionality put it into search but
then i thought well okay i can't see why
it's there
the
all right uh so the question is about
the azure signalr service um
we're getting into a scaling discussion
here uh so i get to tell my story how i
ddos myself how about that
when
if i go back a whole bunch of slides
i really should put a slide in here for
this because it's super useful
uh let's go to this slide this is a good
slide i had an app we built on signalr
dot net framework uh so old signalr had
this philosophy where i could have
multiple hubs
and
only one websocket so uh the
the concept was like mvc controllers
you'd have a hub for different different
ideas
so we would
create multiple hubs for for accounts
for users for this for that and they all
used one websocket when we made the
refactoring to.net core at the time and
they rewrote signalr
they changed the philosophy and said
well it's a websocket per hub
so i have five hubs
so imagine five low lines going to
each client
each client 5 10 15 20 25 so on so on
now uh our users
would instinctively always have 10 to 15
tabs open just by the because of how the
application works
multiply that by thousands
of users at any one time
we pushed the changes live and went oh
this is working great until we hit our
peak time at 10 am east coast time
that first monday
and
i keep getting emails from the clients
that say
this server's really slow
all right let's figure out what's
happening server is restarting itself i
had three servers running in a load
balance set it kept restarting itself
every
every couple minutes because it was
running out of memory
it was exhausting all the sockets on
that server because not only was it web
sockets
html requests javascript request css so
on so on just regular api calls
so i was killing these servers
all right
like
have you ever had to do
a refactoring on the fly under stress
like that's that was me for the next 12
hours was refactoring this application
to get it down to two
hubs while maintaining all the
functionality not breaking anything
so the the lesson learned there was you
only want to have one websocket
per app really
to bring that to
azure single r service
uh azure signalr service
solves two problems
one it takes the socket connections off
your server
so let's imagine azure's over here
your app doesn't connect to your server
it connects the azure signalr service
and then proxy's request to your server
so automatically you're cutting every
websocket connection
from your server you don't have to
manage it that's that's great
uh that's great if you have
stable predictable load
it's not great if you have peaks and
valleys um i actually have a whole
section on this in the course i'm not
trying to push the course but i have a
whole section on it uh plus like math of
the pricing
because it's the pricing is the reason
we didn't use it in this scenario uh
because our peak was
however many thousand connections
and they do daily billing and not hourly
billing so we couldn't scale just for
the four-hour period
that we needed it we'd have to scale it
for the entire day and wasn't cost
effective
the
other thing it does is it acts as a back
plane
so if i have multiple servers in a load
balance set
there's a problem
if i have multiple servers
load balanced if i say clients.all
well
that's really just all the clients on
that server
doesn't necessarily include this all the
clients on the other servers
so if i'm connected to server a
and someone else is on server c
then they're not going to get my message
we have a way of solving that it's
called a backplane you can use redis
which is amazing back plane that you can
host yourself
or you can use azure signalr service
that takes care of that for you
automatically um
so i'm not sure if that answers your
question it's a very specific scaling
um case where
you know if you don't have that many
users you don't have that much load
azure signal or service is not
necessarily for you i wouldn't spend the
months 50 us dollars for
one can up to a thousand connections um
which is actually a good deal
but
you don't need it oh live cad uses azure
signal or service because we have
predictable load all the time we know
exactly what we're paying for we pay for
two units all the time
so 100 us dollars to
basically take all the stress off the
server
for
socket management the biggest reason we
did that was not only
our users
firehouses and emergency services we
also have people that like to listen to
police scanners and just are really nosy
on what's going on they pay us uh
donations so they can see all that data
um
i'm not sure if that's a is that a thing
over here people just like to listen to
police scanners and no you're all not
nosy like that it's just an american
thing okay cool uh
i would totally believe that if you said
yes kevin that's totally an american
thing
um
but that's that's the big use case for
azure signal or service you could
technically write your own if you wanted
to
i don't remember it might have been date
of david fowler
the gentleman who wrote signalr
he does a demo
which he might have done at ndc 2020
where he writes basically writes his own
signalr service
there's not a lot of documentation on
that and i think there should be because
you could technically write your own if
you wanted to but that's an excellent
question thank you sir
yes
uh you would um what i was just talking
about having backplane
so it's a
the servers connect to
uh something that lets them communicate
with each other
whether that's azure signal or service
that you have to pay for or you can use
your own with redis server or redis um
azure redis cache works fine we use that
you can set up your own reddit server
talk to that man about redis
that's
that's the cheaper alternative and works
great we use it for hundreds of users an
hour
without any issue and i've other apps
where we've done thousands of users
but that's the way you solve it is you
tell all your servers connect to this
redis server
and they will pub sub messages between
each other
so
uh
the server in
new york
just sent a message the server in london
hears about it picks it up and sends it
out to all of its users
yes sir
i'm sorry say that a little ladder
that's a great question the signalr
guarantee message deliverability no
actually have a whole article on it on
my site um there's not a mechanism in
signalr to
that can acknowledge messages coming
back and forth between the servers and
the clients the best you can do
is the clients can
can get an acknowledgement from the
server that it successfully sent a
message upstream
but there's no acknowledgement of the
server sending messages down to clients
that's because connections are finicky
if i'm a websocket and a websocket gets
disconnected
i kind i know about that immediately
but if i'm using server sent events or
long polling i might not know about that
disconnection for up to 15 minutes after
it's occurred
and how many thousands of messages could
have potentially been sent in that time
so signalr doesn't guarantee it their
documentation says they don't guarantee
it it's more
it needs to be used as a pub sub so
you're just yelling out into
the
out into the world that something's
happened and whoever needs to listen for
that message listens for it but not
necessarily
there's no acknowledgement model
yep
the the big thing we do is that we uh
we look at connection events so i get an
event on both the client and the server
when a connection gets cut
the client's most important because the
client's going to know if it's
disconnected before the server does
when the client gets connect
disconnected
gets severed it's immediately going to
attempt to reconnect there's automatic
reconnection built into well not built
in you have to turn it on
so automatically try to reconnect
when but as soon as it's disconnected
we
put up a message that says you're
disconnected we don't know what the
current data is it's it's a big warning
as soon as a reconnection occurs
which usually it does it reconnects
right away
as soon as a reconnection occurs we
assume all of our local state is bad
and we immediately go to the server and
says i need
fresh state pretend i just loaded i need
everything i might need to know and we
invalidate everything on the client
the cert in the server
because the server might still be trying
to send me messages
and those messages may or may not be
getting through
so we put it on the client to
reestablish the state of the page as it
needs to be
yeah definitely
oh so um uh so the question is that
then first that i'm maintaining state on
the clients
if i have to go back and ask the server
for for new snapshot yes yeah so if i go
back to livecad
i'll just use livecat as an example and
i'm a moment over my time
so we are maintaining all this local
state at the moment uh so i'm using
vue.js underneath the scenes with vuex
for save management
oh see it just refreshed
um
when i get disconnected for any way any
reason
as soon as i reconnect i do throw all
this away
and i go to the server and we have a
process we call it a resync i'll say i
am
looking at
this configuration please tell me
everything i need to know like don't
assume i have any information
as soon as i get that resync
i start listening for updates um
and we just go back into the cycle we
had before now for mission critical
stuff like this we also have a sub
process every
couple minutes we'll just do a check in
to make sure that we have the current
state of the application um we
we just assume
we just assume local states gonna go
might get disrupted for any reason
that never happens
unless you have a disconnection event
and then you know about it
um
we just we do it as a sanity check just
in case uh but you don't it's not
necessary
um
yep stuff's updating oh it's going flash
right on it so this is what happens in a
firehouse during an emergency um
so some trucks get dispatched and
hopefully they go put that fire out
did that answer your question
yes sir
yes
theoretically the
the
roslin analyzers for async await should
catch it
because it's returning a task so it
should identify hey we're returning a
task
obviously you'll want to wait on this uh
in
that particular case i don't think they
had the analyzers turned on or they were
ignoring that one
yes steve
you could just return a task
yeah you did yeah you actually don't
have to do the await yourself you can
just return the task
so yeah one more time
i don't remember off top of my head
all right friends well i'll stick around
for a moment if you have any other
questions but thank you all for coming
out